got a tough draw on that say that on
camera the leafs would be so excited
that you said that i know i'm going to
say it again john say it again i said it
i said good luck to the leafs yeah you
know
it's a tough first round matchup the
playoffs are starting we're very excited
go blues all right they haven't won
since 1967 just to put it in perspective
i'm very aware
this movie is insane it is absolutely
incredible i don't like i just want to
say
thank you like this is just a moment i
know it's been a while since you guys
made the film but has it sunk in that
this is one of the biggest cinematic
experiences people are going to go
through you know we're very excited for
many reasons obviously part of it is is
just the anticipation of this movie
coming out we've finished this film in
2019 and we've been sitting on it for a
couple of years now so uh obviously tom
and and jerry bruckheimer and paramount
everybody really wanted this movie to be
seen as it should be seen which is on a
very very big screen very loud with a
bunch of people a lot of high fives um
and i think that that is what is going
to happen we're very excited for this to
be seen only in theaters and uh it's
it's a it's a movie that that
you can watch it on your phone if you
want but it's way better it's so much
better when it's really loud so what did
you say to tom the first time you
watched the film in in its entirety i i
i honestly i got a little teared up i
i'll tell the story of we saw it in
lockdown we saw it in a theater on the
paramount lot it was about 15 or 20 of
us cast members we were all sitting 10
seats apart and with masks on and
everything and
it was a weird and scary time but we
were all blown away by the film and then
i got home and my phone rang and it was
tom
and he said what do you think
and i
i i almost broke down i was like it's so
good it's just so good you should be so
proud of it you're so good in it the
movie is so good it's beautiful to look
at and it's and it's inspiring and it's
exciting and exhilarating and all of
those things
and then i said when are we gonna when
are people gonna see it this is in 2020.
so it's it's finally coming out i'm very
excited for people to see it and i know
he is too yeah and you shared a story
that you watched football with him i
think it was like kimmel's with his mom
and so how is he on set compared to
being offset like he's the same guy i
mean he's he's he's the hardest working
guy on the set and and there's a reason
for that he's so proud of this franchise
this is the thing that you know may
essentially made him the movie star that
he is there's very few people that get
their name above the title like he does
there's very few people that have that
place in our firmament these days and
and they're few and far between and i
can't think of another guy that's been a
movie star for four decades right you
know he started when he was 18 years old
and he's been going ever since and
at a very high level so there's he's a
he's a wonderful he's a wonderful guy
he's a great boss and he's a great
leader and it was a it was a thrill to
get to work with him now i was hoping
you were going to go through all the
training that like miles called it it's
called cruise boot camp i was waiting to
see you go into the air i mean how would
you have done that with that extensive
training that those g's and hitting them
i like to think i would have done okay
yeah i i'm very glad i didn't have to
find out you gotta do it tom you gotta
put him through the training you got to
do it he was very he was very excited to
get me up there and i was like but i
don't have to right and he said no you
don't have to well then okay
it's all very expensive we should we
should save it for the kids that need it
36 years since tom top gun and here we
are with the the next one and it's
incredible they gave him the name
maverick 36 years ago what nickname
would you give to him now after working
with him he will always in forever be
maverick i mean that really is it
describes him to a t it just certainly
describes this character
uh i mean just just looking at him on
the on the poster holding that helmet
it's such a great
image and uh and it really is uh it
really does embody his his his life his
force his career is everything you rock
thank you so much